once upon a time there was a dear little
girl who was lost by everyone who looked
at her but most of all by her
grandmother there was nothing that she
would not have given the child once she
gave her a little red cap of velvet
which suited her so well that she would
never wear anything else and so she
would always be called it's already cap
one day her mother said to her come
little redcap here is a piece of cake
and a bottle of wine take these to your
grandmother she is ill and she is weak
and these will do her good set out
before it gets hot and when you will go
and walk nicely and quietly and do not
run off the path we may fall and break
the bottle and then your grandmother
will get nothing and when you get into
her room don't forget to say good
morning and don't peep into every corner
before you do so the grandmother lived
out in the wood half a league away from
the village and just as little redcap
entered the wood she was greeted by a
wolf redcap did not know what a wicked
creature he was and so she was not
afraid of him at all where do you go so
early little redcap
to my grandmother's what do you have in
your apron little redcap I have some
cake and wine yesterday was bacon day
supports it grandmothers to have
something good to make her stronger and
where does your grandmother live little
redcap
a good quarter of a league further on in
the wood her house stands under three
large oak trees the nut trees are just
below you surely must know it replied
little redcap the wolf thought to
himself what a tender young creature
what a nice plump mouthful she'll be
better to eat than a old woman I must
act craftily as to catch them both so he
walked for a short time by the side of
little redcap and then he said see
little redcap
how pretty the flowers are about here
why do you not look around I believe you
do not hear how sweetly the birds sing
you walk so gravely as if you're going
to school while everything else here is
so merry little road cap raised her eyes
and when she saw the sunbeams dancing
here and through the trees and pretty
flowers growing everywhere
she thought suppose I take grandmother's
and fresh flowers that will please her
too it's so early on in a day that I
shall still get there in good time and
so she ran from the path and into the
wood to look for flowers and whenever
she had picked one she fancied that
there would still be a prettier one
further on and ran after it and got
deeper and deeper into the wood
meanwhile the wolf ran straight to the
grandmother's house and
knocked at the door who is their little
red cap replied the wolf she's bringing
cake and wine open the door if the latch
called out the grandmother I am too weak
and I cannot get up
the wolf lifted the latch in the door
flew open and without saying a word he
went straight to grandmother's bed and
devoured her then he put on her clothes
dressed in her cap he laid himself in
her bed and drew the curtains literate
cap however had been running around
picking flowers and when she gathered so
many that she could not carry no more
she remembered her grandmother and set
out on her way she was surprised to find
the cottage door standing open and when
she went into the room she had such a
strange feeling and she said to herself
oh dear how uneasy I feel today and
other times I like being with
grandmother so much she called out good
morning but received no answer she went
to the bed and drew back the curtains
and there lay her grandmother with her
cap pulled over her face and looking
very strange Oh grandmother she said
what big ears you have the better to
hear you with my child was the reply but
grandmother what big eyes you have the
better to see you my dear but
grandmother what large hands you have
the better to hug you with but
grandmother what a terrible large mouth
you have the better to eat you with and
scarcely had the wolf said this that
with one bound he was out of bed and he
swallowed redcap hole
when the wolf appease his appetite he
lay down in the bed and fell asleep
he began to snore very loud the hunter
who was just passed in the house thought
himself how the old woman was snoring
very loudly I must see if she wants
anything so he went into the room and
when he came to the bed he saw that the
wolf was lying in it do I find you here
old sinner said he I have long sought
you then just as he was going to fire at
it it occurred to him that a wolf may
have devoured the old grandmother and
she might still be saved so he did not
fire he instead took a pair of scissors
and began to cut up in the stomach of
the sleeping wolf when he had made two
snips he saw a little red cap shining
and then he made to snip small and then
little girl sprang out crying and after
that the aged grandmother came out alive
also but scarcely able to breathe redcap
however quickly fetched great stones in
which they filled the wolf's belly
and when he awoke he wanted to run away
but the stones filled his belly so heavy
that he was unable he fell down at once
and fell dead
all three were delighted the haunted
roof the wolf skin and went home with it
the grandmother ate the cake and drank
the wine which redcap bought her and was
revived but redcap thought to herself as
long as I live I will never buy myself
leave the path to run into the wood when
my mother has forbidden me to do so
redcap was once again taking cakes to
her grandmother another wolf spoke to
her and tried to entice her from the
path redcap however was on her guard and
went straight forward on her way and
told her grandmother that she had met
the wolf and that he said good morning
to her but was such a wicked look in his
eyes if it had not been on a public road
she was certain he would have eaten her
up while we will shut the door so he may
not come in soon afterwards the wolf
knocked on the door and cried
open the door grandmother I am little
redcap fetching you some cake but they
did not speak nor open the door so the
graybeard stole twice or thrice around
the house and lastly he jumped on the
roof intending to wait until a redcap
was home in the evening and then steal
her away and devour her in the darkness
but the grandmother sworn to his
thoughts in front of the house does a
great stone trowel
I made some sausages yesterday take the
water in which I bowled them to the
trowel where it kept carried until the
great travels form then this one of the
sausages reached a wolf and he sniffed
and peeped down and at last he stretched
out he's next so far and he could no
longer keep his foot in and he began to
slip he slipped down from the roof and
straight into the great trowel and
drowned but red cap went joyously home
and never did anything to harm anyone
the story of little red cap is one that
I'm sure nearly everyone Cora enough has
heard of but it's likely the virgin knew
had to may have been called Little Red
Riding Hood at first glance the story is
a very simple tale that warns of the
danger in talking to strangers and those
who wish the trick and take advantage of
you but there are several interesting
versions of the story the first
published version of the story was
written by the French author Charles
Perrault in the 17th century in fact
much of Peru's work would later be
rewritten by the Brothers Grimm
Burroughs version centers around a young
wild brood village girl who's tricked by
a wolf who lays a trap in her
grandmother's house he then of course
eats the girl but there is no woodcutter
or hunter
certainly is no happy ending as it is
the wolf that emerges victorious in this
story piroso explanation of his story
was that it was a warning to young or
bred ladies to avoid listening to
strangers a many saw his version as an
early warning of pedophilia in the
Brothers Grimm version of the tale it's
very clear that the first story warns
against the naivety and the trust of
strangers the second I was almost the
Brothers Grimm shown us what happens if
you listen to the warnings of the first
story and applied into the same
situation this time you and ready cap
can emerge the victor rather than the
victim the story of red cap as I'm sure
many of you are aware has been adapted
several times over the years each time
becoming more and more tame so feel free
to share any versions of the story that
you may have heard with me in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology in fiction explained
[Music]